Der Helipilot
macht sich an die Arbeit
und auch wir steigen auf in den Hang.
Was ist das da?
Das ist der Lawinengraben,
wo die Lawine runterkam.
Die hat das Holz
teilweise schon mitgenommen.
Hoppla! Ich gehe besser hier hoch.
Da hat es Löcher. Man muss aufpassen.
Ich bin mit Mario und Simon
von der Helikopter-Crew unterwegs.
Immer ein Forstwart und ein
Flughelfer bilden zusammen ein Team.
Insgesamt
arbeiten drei Teams im Hang.
Ich kann es dir gleich zeigen.
- Ja.
Flughelfer Simon aus dem Bernbiet
gibt mir die Instruktionen dafür,
wie man die Bäume
für den Transport vorbereitet.
Es ist ein ganz einfaches System:
Du kannst das
einfach hier so einhängen.
Ja. Und das hält?
Ja.
Um es zu sichern ...
... machst du ein Stück Holz
so rein,
damit es etwas klemmt.
- Okay.
Das sieht eher nach einem Patent aus,
das ich machen würde.
So ein bisschen improvisiert,
schnell etwas rein.
Hält das? Ist das zuverlässig?
Es geht nur darum, dass es hält,
bis der Helikopter angezogen hat.
Mit dem Gewicht
geht das dann nicht mehr auf.- Gut.
Du kannst mit Mario mit.
- Ja, genau.
* Helikopter *
Jetzt kommt er. Ist das unserer?
- Ja.
Sicherheit ist das Wichtigste.
Regel Nummer 1:
immer weg aus der Gefahrenzone.
(Funkspruch) Drei, zwei, eins, null.
* Ruhige Musik *
Rund 200 Flüge braucht es,
bis alle Stämme weg sind.
Mario und seine Forstwartkollegen
haben tagelang Bäume gefällt
und für den Helitransport
vorbereitet.
Das kleinere Zeugs lasst ihr liegen,
oder?
Das lassen wir liegen.
Was im Weg ist, kommt weg.
Den Rest lassen wir.
Wir machen das,
um etwas Licht reinzubringen
und jungen Bäumen
eine Chance zu geben,
damit sie
in die Höhe wachsen können.
Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen,
man würde den Wald
am besten natürlich lassen.
Wenn der Wind etwas fällt,
lässt man es liegen,
weil es in der Natur so ist.
- Aber wir brauchen den Wald ja.
Der Wald braucht uns nicht.
Wir brauchen ihn
für den Schutz vor Lawinen
und sonstigen Naturgewalten.
Ja.
- Wir brauchen ihn einfach.
Wir machen das für uns,
nicht für den Wald.- Ja.
Schlussendlich geht es um uns, ja.
Ich gebe dir das da rüber.
Ja, ich sehe es.
- Hast du es?
Ja, ich habe es.
Du kannst gut hier warten.
Warte hier!
Dann erlebe ich live
warum es gut ist,
wenn man weit genug wegsteht.
Dort rollt einer.
- Ja.
Das ist ja mega gefährlich.
Dieser Stamm
nimmt dich nicht gerade mit,
wenn hier aber grössere stehen,
gehst du mehr zur Seite.
Dann stellst du dich oben hin.
Man versucht immer wegzustehen.
Einfach, damit nichts geschieht.
Simon und Mario
sind beide die Ruhe in Person.
Das müsse man sein,
sonst mache man Fehler, sagen sie.
Und Fehler
sind in diesem Job schnell fatal.
Hattest du schon einen Unfall
oder hast du
eine gefährliche Situation erlebt?
Im zweiten Lehrjahr ...
... hatte ich einen Unfall.
Man sieht die Spuren noch.
Das ist davon?
- Ein Kickback.
Was heisst ...
- Es traf mich in der Schulter.
Ich war nicht konzentriert.
Es war nachmittags
nach der 15-Uhr-Pause.
Wir hatten angefangen,
wieder zu arbeiten.
Ich wollte etwas absägen
und die Säge schnellte zurück.
Die Motorsäge
ist dir ins Gesicht geflogen?
Ja, hier am Gesicht vorbei
und in die Schulter.
Wäre der Winkel
ein bisschen anders gewesen ...
Ja, wenn die in den Hals wäre,
dann ist fertig.
Das ist so, aber ...
Das ist ... der Job.
Jeden Morgen,
wenn ich in den Spiegel schaue:
"Ja, voilà,
das hast du dir selber eingebrockt."
Mit der Forstwirtschaft aufzuhören
habe er sich trotzdem nie überlegt,
sagt Mario,
auch wenn er die Spuren des Unfalls
für den Rest seines Lebens
im Gesicht trägt.
Der Wind wird stärker.
Das macht es heikel,
Bäume rauszufliegen.
Ich sehe noch mal bei Simon zu,
wie das Anhängen geht.
Denn jetzt gilt es ernst für mich.
Du kannst den hier dann anhängen.
Das hier nennt man das Nüsschen.
- Das Nüsschen?
Ja, genau.
- Gut.
Die Klinke hat zwei Schächte.
Den einfach in einen rein.
Reinlegen?
- Du musst es so reinstossen.
Okay.
- Aber ich bin auch da.
Zwei.
Einer.
Genau so. Ist gut.
Du kannst ziehen.
Das gibt extrem Adrenalin.
Ich dachte erst, es sei,
weil ich den Hang hochgerannt bin,
aber das ist wegen dieser Gewalt,
die da auf einen zukommt.
Das ist krass.
Ich habe ein bisschen ...
Ha!
Der Puls geht etwas schneller.
- Mega viel schneller.
Noch einmal.
Schon ist der nächste Stamm
an der Reihe.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gut.
Aber das ist für den Moment
der letzte Flug für den Heli.
Das Wetter sieht zwar prächtig aus,
die Windböen sind aber so stark,
dass Fliegen zu gefährlich wäre.
(Funkspruch)
Wie sieht es bei euch oben aus?
Böen seit einer Stunde.
Oben bläst ein starker Wind.
- Ja.
Wir müssen warten,
bis der Wind nachlässt.
Auch die anderen Teams stehen rum
und können nicht arbeiten.
Eine Zwangspause auch für Maik.
Die Messstation
hat über 80 km/h angezeigt, Windböe.
Das ist genug.
- Ja.
Dann wird es heute nicht besser.
- Nein.
Morgen wird es besser.
So lange musste ich noch nie warten.
(Funkspruch) An alle:
Wir brechen die Übung ab.
Die Crew aus dem Wald
kann zurückkommen.
Jawohl, Übung für heute abgebrochen.
Hallo zusammen.
- (Männer) Salü.
Hoi miteinander.
Ihr konntet auch nicht viel machen.
- Nein.
Das Gegenteil
passiert sicher auch oft:
dass ihr fliegt,
bis es dunkel wird, oder?
Er nickt. Schau!
* Lachen *
Kennst du das?
- Das kommt oft vor.
Es ist eigentlich normal,
dass es länger geht,
und nicht umgekehrt, so wie heute.
Aber ja ...
Die Lektion des heutigen Tages:
Die Natur gibt den Takt an.
Die Waldarbeiter von Forst Aletsch
sind sich gewohnt,
dass das Wetter
alles auf den Kopf stellen kann.
Fütterst du Fliegen?
- Was?
(Alle) Priis.
* Lachen *
Zum Glück ist Feierabend.
* Ruhige Musik *
Gut.
7 Uhr morgens und ich bin schon
wieder mit Mario und Maik unterwegs -
ausgerüstet mit einer Motorsäge
und einem Spezialgerät,
um Bäume zu entrinden.
Der nächste Steilhang wartet schon.
Boah!
Hier rauf?
- Ja.- Okay.
Hey du.
Frühsport inbegriffen.
Wir steigen zu einem Wald auf,
in dem letztes Jahr
der Borkenkäfer gewütet hat.
Was übrig geblieben ist,
sieht wie ein Schlachtfeld aus.
Das ist jetzt
ein grösseres Käfernest.
Hier hat man angefangen, die Bäume
zu fällen und zu entrinden.
Ein paar Tage später
war hier wieder einer und hier.
Wie meinst du das?
- Zusätzlich abgestorbene Bäume,
die sie am Vortag
noch nicht so gesehen hatten.
Aha! Geht das so schnell?
- Hier ging alles ziemlich schnell.
Also, die ganze Fläche ...
... ist wegen des Borkenkäfers so,
nicht wegen eines Sturms.
Ja.
- Okay.
Die Forstwarte
kamen irgendwann nicht mehr nach.
Der Käfer
konnte immer mehr Bäume angreifen,
weil es so warm und trocken war.
All diese hellen Fichten sind tot.
Einen Teil
habt ihr trotzdem stehen lassen.
Ja,
irgendwann wird die Fläche zu gross,
wenn man weiter fällt und fällt.
Das ist tatsächlich euer Problem:
Es fällt jetzt
der ganze Schutzwald weg.
Ja, und hier unten ist das Dorf.
Das geht wieder 30 bis 40 Jahre,
bis die Bäume so mannshoch stehen.
30 bis 40 Jahre?
- Ja, bis es einen Schutz gibt.
Fast 90 % der Wälder im Wallis
haben eine Schutzfunktion.
Wenn sie fehlen,
müssen Lawinenverbauungen hin.
Die sind nicht nur hässlich,
sondern auch teuer.
Man hört immer vom Borkenkäfer,
aber ich habe noch nie einen gesehen.
Denkst du, er sei gross oder klein?
* Lachen *
Die Kleinen sind immer die
Gemeinsten, sagt meine Erfahrung.
Also, er ist nicht gross, oder?
- Nein, er ist klein. Bis 5 mm.
Hier siehst du einen.
So, jetzt haben wir ihn.
So, das ist der Käfer.
Er sieht harmlos aus.
- Ja, die Masse macht es aus.
Das Männchen bohrt sich ein,
dann kommt das Weibchen dazu.
Hier ist die Rammelkammer,
wo sie ...
Heisst das so?
- Ja. Dann weisst du, was passiert.
Ja ...
* Lachen *
Wie viele Junge machen sie?
- 40 in einem Brutbild.
Das Problem ist die Zeit zwischen
dem Einbohren und dem Ausfliegen.
Das dauert je nach Temperatur
vier bis sechs Wochen.
Und bis du diese Bäume
in diesem ganzen Revier findest ...
Das Grundproblem ist,
dass man einfach schon ...
... zu spät ist, um herauszufinden,
wo es ein Nest hat, oder?
Vielfach schon.
- Ja.
Meistens fangen sie
im obersten Drittel an.
Aha!
- Dort beginnen sie zu bohren,
nicht unten,
wo du gerade hinschauen kannst.
Du musst
mit dem Feldstecher schauen.
Wenn es tagsüber oder nachts ein
wenig windet, ist das Bohrmehl weg.
Dann siehst du es nicht mehr.
Der Regen wäscht es auch weg.
Die Ruhe hat ein Ende.
Der Borkenkäfer bohrt sich gerne
in die Rinde von Bäumen,
die wegen Sturm oder Schnee
umgekippt sind - wie dieser hier.
Um ein Käfernest zu verhindern,
entrinden sie den Baum.
30 Minuten Knochenarbeit
für einen einzelnen Baum.
Es braucht schon Teamarbeit, oder?
Ja.
- Ja, ja.
Man muss aufpassen,
wenn man am gleichen Baum arbeitet.
So ist es.
Wenn oben etwas rutscht,
hat der unten Pech.
Darum ist es gut,
wenn man sich gut kennt und weiss,
dass der andere keinen Fehler macht.
Das gibt einen guten Zusammenhalt.
Man erlebt miteinander
halt auch Situationen,
die unter Umständen
ans Lebendige gehen können.
Ja, ja. Das ist definitiv so, ja.
Ich habe gehört, dass ihr vor ...
... Kurzem hier in der Gegend
einen tödlichen Unfall hattet.
Ein Berufskollege,
den ihr sicher gekannt habt.
Was macht das mit euch?
Ja, man ist geschockt
und am Boden zerstört,
weil man ihn kannte.
Ja. Kanntest du ihn gut?
- Ja.
Wir haben bis letztes Jahr
mit ihm zusammengearbeitet.
Er war in unserem Betrieb
und hat gewechselt.
Und ja ... Wenn das passiert,
kannst du es nicht glauben.
Man denkt: "Wie ist das passiert?"
Und wenn du dann
wieder arbeiten gehst,
v.a. die ersten Tage,
überlegst du es dir zweimal ...
... ob du das so oder so
machen solltest.
Das hat mich letzte Woche
auch stark beschäftigt.
Das fährt ein.
Es ist schwierig umzustellen
und sich wieder voll auf die Arbeit
zu konzentrieren.
Das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Aber eben:
Wir wollen ja
auf diesem Beruf weiterarbeiten.
Man kann sich das nicht von
einer Angst kaputt machen lassen.
Aber das wird immer ...
Man wird immer daran denken.
Das wird dir immer
in Erinnerung bleiben.
Ja ...
- Wie schnell es halt gehen kann.
Ja.- Man hat sich gerade
noch gesehen, dann ist er weg.
Ja.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Forstwart ist der gefährlichste Beruf
der Schweiz.
Drei von zehn Forstwarten
verletzen sich pro Jahr,
sagt die Statistik der
Schweizerischen Unfallversicherung.
Hier in den Walliser Steilhängen
ist das Risiko noch höher.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Jetzt gehen wir zu Peter.
Er hat etwas vorbereitet.
Peter?
- Ja, zu unserem Chef.- Okay.
Der Chef habe eine Art Wunderwaffe
gegen den Borkenkäfer organisiert.
Hallo zusammen.
- (Alle) Hallo.
Ist das der Chef?
Mona.
- Peter. Sali, Mona.
Freut mich. Hallo miteinander.
- Servus.
Ich habe gehört,
du hättest  d i e  Wunderwaffe
gegen den Borkenkäfer am Start.
Ja.
- Zeigst du mir sie?
Das ist ein Borkenkäfersuchhund
von Leopold Slotta aus Österreich.
Er ist heute extra angereist,
um uns seinen Hund ...
... bei der Arbeit, bei einem
praktischen Einsatz zu zeigen ...
Sarek, komm her! Komm her zu mir!
... um die Borkenkäferbäume
zu finden.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden:
Du bist die neue Wunderwaffe?
Er weiss es nur noch nicht.
Er weiss es noch nicht.
- Nein. Das ist Sarek.
Er ist
ein fünfjähriger Australian Kelpie.
Er hilft, Borkenkäfer zu suchen.
Ob er letztendlich die Wunderwaffe
ist, trauen wir uns nicht zu sagen,
aber er ist sicher
ein wichtiges Puzzlestück
im Kampf gegen den Borkenkäfer.
So, komm raus!
Er ist schon weg.
Sarek schnüffelt sich durch den Wald.
Seine Nase ist
rund 100'000-mal feiner als unsere
und extra darauf trainiert,
die Sexuallockstoffe des Borkenkäfers
zu riechen.
So findet er befallene Bäume,
bevor sie krank aussehen.
* Lockere Musik *
* Bellen *
Man sieht, dass sich der Hund
für diesen Baum interessiert.
Nachdem er einige Zeit unterwegs war
und nichts gefunden hat,
nimmt er das,
was halbwegs danach riecht.
So, gut, super.
Letztes Jahr
hatte es in diesem Baum Käfer.
Gut für den Wald,
aber schwierig für den Spürhund:
Wegen des kalten und nassen Frühlings
sind die Käfer noch nicht so aktiv.
Aber dann zeigt er etwas an.
* Bellen *
Platz.
Das könnte etwas sein,
wenn ich mir den so ansehe.
Ohne die Bäume gut zu kennen,
sieht der so aus,
als könnten Borkenkäfer drin sein.
Das ist keine exakte Wissenschaft.
Wir arbeiten mit Lebewesen und es
gibt auch immer wieder Unschärfen.
Wenn du dir den Baum ansiehst:
Was sagst du?
Könnte das ein Kandidat sein?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Er hat unten zwar Äste,
die dürr sind,
aber weiter oben sieht man,
dass die Krone grün ist.
Ich bin mir nicht zu 100 % sicher,
ob wir den fällen sollten.
Im Walliser Schutzwald
zählt jeder Baum.
Peter Aschilier will die Fichte
zuerst genauer beobachten.
Ein paar Wochen später
behält Sarek übrigens recht:
In diesem Baum hat es wirklich Käfer.
Forst Aletsch will es probieren:
Schon bald wird der erste Schweizer
Borkenkäferspürhund ausgebildet.
Ja, fein. Ja, brav.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mona, nimmst du die Latte?
Das sollte gehen.
Ihr kommt aber auch mit, oder? Ich
muss es nicht alleine machen.- Ja.
Du sagst, wenn du wechseln willst.
Meine Hände wären frei.
Ich dachte, ich müsse etwas tragen.
Ich tue jetzt so,
als wäre ich für etwas brauchbar.
Unser nächster Job:
einen Zaun flicken.
Und richtig geraten:
Es geht wieder bergauf.
Wo man hinsieht, sieht man
angeknabberte Bäume und Pflanzen.
Das sind Fichten,
die vom Wild zerbissen werden.
Sie werden zu Krüppeln.
Hirsche und Rehe machen die Rinde
kaputt oder knabbern die Triebe ab.
Die Schutzbäume kommen so jahrelang
auf keinen grünen Zweig
oder sterben sogar ab.
* Lockere Musik *
Das Wild sei im Aletschgebiet
ein echtes Problem,
darum haben die Forstwarte
hier einen Zaun gebaut.
In seinem Schutz
ist ein starker Wald gewachsen,
der die Strasse und die Bahnstrecke
schützt.
Hier könnten sie auch durch?
- Ja, ja.
Wirklich? Aber wie?
- Ja, die ...
Hochsprung?
Nein, ein Reh oder eine Hirschkuh
gehen da durch.
Problemlos.
Du kannst da mittig vorbohren.
Etwa so?
- Ja, ja. Tipptopp.
Dieser Wildschutzzaun
steht schon über 30 Jahre.
Ende der 80er-Jahre starben an
diesem Hang plötzlich alle Föhren ab.
Alarmstufe Rot. Ohne Massnahmen
wäre der ganze Hang erodiert.
Wir haben Pflanzen gesetzt.
Wir haben sie in Töpfen vorbereitet.
6'500 Pflanzen.
Dann sagten wir, wir würden
einen Zaun um die Fläche machen,
damit im Winter
kein Rotwild hier drin ist.
Damit sie uns nicht
die jungen Pflanzen abfressen.
Ein gutes Beispiel
ist der Wacholder.
Der z.B. oder der da unten.
Die sind 2,5 m hoch.
Ausserhalb des Zaunes
siehst du die nie so hoch.
Die sind dann nur so hoch.
Der Wald sollte sich
selber verjüngen können,
aber er wird immer abgefressen.
- Jawohl.
Ich als Laie würde sagen,
wir haben zu viele Rehe oder Hirsche.
Ja, der Wildbestand
ist jetzt auf einem Höchststand.
Müsste man sie abschiessen?
- Ja, man muss sie abschiessen.
Du hast mich erwischt.
- Ja, oder? Siehst du das so?
Was ist das Problem?
Wollen sie nicht mehr abschiessen?
Ich bin ... Viele haben Angst,
es gäbe dann keine mehr.
Das ist die Kunst, mit der
Jagdbehörde und der Waldbehörde ...
... zu verhandeln, um eine Balance
zu finden, die stimmt.
Man findet sicher eine Lösung,
wenn man beides will.
Ein heikles Thema -
und die Zeit drängt.
Das Wild hat mit dem Borkenkäfer
etwas gemeinsam:
Beide sind gerne
an den warmen Südhängen.
Der Käfer tötet die älteren Bäume,
das Wild frisst die jungen.
Eine explosive Mischung
für den Walliser Schutzwald.
* Knacken *
Im Werkhof von Forst Aletsch
wird das Holz auch verarbeitet -
quasi der Abschluss eines Baumlebens.
Ich habe heute
mit dem Anfang des Ganzen zu tun:
Wir pflanzen Bäume.
Was ist das jetzt?
Das ist die Garage meines Göttis.
Das ist der Kühlraum, die Kühlzelle.
Das sind all die Pflanzen,
die wir gesammelt haben.
Das waren über 5'000 Wildlinge.
Die haben wir Ende März,
Anfang April gesammelt.
Dann haben wir sie auf die Säcke
aufgeteilt und sie angeschrieben,
damit wir wissen, woher sie sind -
wegen der Höhe usw.
Also, hier sind ...
... 125 Lärchen.
- So viel Stück sind da drin, genau.
"Visperterminen".
- Dort haben wir sie geholt.
Okay.
Bäumchen aus dem Gartencenter
würden hier nicht wachsen.
Darum haben Maik und Mario die
Wildlinge in der Region gesammelt -
meistens an den Strassenrändern,
wo sie eh nur stören würden.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Also, ich meine, ihr seid ja ...
... knapp 30 - du noch nicht mal -
und ihr hört Ländlermusik?
Ich höre das noch gerne.
- Wirklich?
Aber ich höre alles -
von Metal bis zu Ländlermusik.
Das ist urchig, wie der Wald auch.
Hier oben kommen wir tatsächlich
noch in den Schnee - im Mai.
So, also.
Gehen wir.
Es ist ein bisschen glatt.
- Ja.
An diesem Hang hat zuerst der Sturm
und dann der Käfer gewütet.
Hier wollen wir
unsere Bäumchen setzen.
Ich würde ja nicht unbedingt
etwas im Schnee pflanzen wollen.
Macht das nichts?
Also hier ist das kein Nachteil.
Der Mai-Schnee ist ja schnell weg.
Zum Pflanzen
ist es eigentlich praktisch.
In der Sonne
muss man extrem aufpassen:
Die Feinwurzeln - diese ganz feinen
Wurzeln, die ganz bleiben sollten -
gehen in der Hitze schnell kaputt.
Darum geht das eigentlich gut.
Der Schnee ist schön ballig.
- Was ist er?
Ballig. Gut für Schneebälle.
Der ist schnell wieder weg.
- Ja.
Föhren und Lärchen haben wir dabei.
Hier sieht man das Bündel.
Wir haben das immer abgezählt.
Das sind 25 Stück zusammen.
Und wieder ab in den Steilhang.
Die Lärche.
Dann mit Erde auffüllen.
Wie alt ist diese Lärche etwa?
Die ist wahrscheinlich
fünf Jahre alt.
Fünf Jahre? Ehrlich?
- Die fangen ganz klein an.
Je nach Standort geht es
in den Bergen schon ziemlich lange.
Und wie lange braucht die,
bis sie so eine Höhe hat?
Ja, bis sie mannshoch sind,
dauert das 20 bis 30 Jahre.
Okay.
- Wenn sie in der Natur wachsen.
Die Jahrringe in den grossen Stämmen
kannst du von Auge gar nicht zählen.
Die sind so eng zusammen,
dass du eine Lupe brauchst.
Und im Mittelland
hast du teils Zentimeter.
Das sind die zähen, die hier wachsen.
- Ja.
Ist das bei den Menschen auch so?
- Die Walliser sind auch Zähe, ja.
Aktiv Bäume pflanzen,
um ein paar Jahre zu gewinnen,
bis der Wald wieder dicht ist
und schützt.
* Ruhige Musik *
Geht es für dich, Mona?
- Ja.
Und dann lerne ich
noch den neusten Lifehack,
um die Bäumchen gegen
das gefrässige Wild zu schützen.
Ich gebe dir das. Du weisst, wie.
- Ja, ich nehme die Handschuhe.
Das ist Schafwolle. Die kann man
nutzen, um Pflanzen zu schützen.
Damit die Rehe und so
die jungen Triebe nicht abfressen?
Ja.
Es muss einfach
ein ungewaschenes Schaf sein.
Du kannst daran riechen.
Du kannst ein bisschen nehmen.
Ja, es böckelt ein wenig.
- Es böckelt, ja.
Wieso nützt das?
- Die mögen den Geruch nicht.
Und du frisst
ja auch nicht gerne Haare.
Also, wissenschaftlich
ist es noch nicht bewiesen.
Aber in Österreich
haben sie schon länger Erfahrung
und sie schwören darauf.
Wir haben letztes Jahr
damit angefangen.
In zwei, drei Jahren
wissen wir mehr.
Es braucht nicht viel.
Reiss ein bisschen ab und leg es so
über die oberste Knospe.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Engelshaar
auf dem Christbaum.
Das kommt mir erst jetzt in den Sinn:
Wir haben die Bäumchen rausgerissen.
Deine Wurzeln sind stark im Wallis,
oder?
Also, du möchtest deine Wurzeln
an keinem anderen Ort, oder?
Nein, da müsstest du dich
anstrengen, um die rauszukriegen.
Die gehen wahrscheinlich
200 m in den Boden.
* Lachen *
Fest verbunden mit der Heimat
und der Natur
und überhaupt gut geerdet
sind Maik und Mario, finde ich.
Zum Abschluss kommen wir
an einem sehr besonderen Baum vorbei:
drei Stämme, eine Wurzel.
Du meine Güte!
Das ist ein Kaliber.
Es ist speziell,
dass der so gross wurde.
Das ist wirklich
ein schöner, spezieller Baum,
der etwas erlebt hat.
Wie alt ist der etwa?
Ich schätze ihn
so auf 400, 450 Jahre.
Wirklich?
- Er ist ziemlich alt.
Der könnte viel darüber erzählen,
was auf diesem Wanderweg los war.
Ich habe Demut vor dem Wald
bzw. vor diesen grossen Bäumen.
Sie überleben uns und es ist wie ...
... etwas, das stehen bleibt,
etwas, das dich herunterholt.
Im Wald
geht einfach alles viel länger,
alles, was passiert.
Vielleicht sollten wir Menschen
auch langfristig denken
und nicht immer schnell hier
und schnell da.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Genau das nehme ich mit.
Mitten im Wald
können wir Weitblick lernen
und Verantwortung übernehmen -
weit über uns
und unsere eigene Gegenwart hinaus.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021